you famously worked in publishing oh yes  I did yes a little while what did you do  we in publishing I have no idea this was  in preparation for Bridget Jones yeah  how long how long did you do it for ah  let's see I went over in January we  started filming after Easter  so come on yeah good good few months  yeah so I mean you must have done  something well yeah I did I got the  coffee I made the coffee I had to you  know cut anything out of you know the  local periodicals or that are about the  authors that the publishing company  represented so I do that and then follow  them away and I had to organize the the  book launches and things like that  yeah well and who do they say you were  they said that I was a Bridget Cavendish  so a relative of the gentleman who was  the owner of the publishers which  explained why I got the job with  absolutely no skills whatsoever  [Music]